[Musique]
c'est un faux intox avec vous Antoine
fenaud bonjour bonjour Raphaël et
aujourd'hui une vidéo d'un très rare
bombardier américain qui sème le doute
oui absolument rafale vous allez le voir
cette vidéo je vais vous la présenter
tout de suite d'abord elle est
issue de plusieurs publications Twitter
notamment ce tweet ici que vous le voyez
en français ce twittos lui en est
convaincu il dit un bombardier B2
américain arrive en Pologne pour la
première fois de l'histoire c'est un
bombardier stratégique ça on va y
revenir il peut transporter 16 missiles
de croisière dotés d'ogives nucléaire la
fameuse toujours menace nucléaire autour
de la guerre en Ukraine la publication
originale en tout cas récente elle vient
ici c'est un compte en ukrainien
naturellement qui le qui le relai avec
donc la vidéo que je vais vous montrer
n'est pas d'un très grand intérêt
qu'est-ce qu'on y voit on y voit juste
ce fameux avion en question qui est donc
un bombardier utilisé uniquement par
l'armée américaine qui va donc je vous
l'accélère qui va donc passer au dessus
de cette de cet homme qui le film pour
atterrir sur cet aérodrome à noter
également que cette vidéo elle a été vue
vous le voyez ici un peu plus de 33000
fois donc Raphaël et pourtant à cet
avion il n'a jamais atterri en Pologne
absolument et c'est là qui est toute
l'astuce en fait et bien cette cet avion
en réalité il atterrissait sur une base
britannique et pour son rendre compte il
suffit de procéder à une recherche
d'image inversée on retombe sur notre
vidéo original que je vous ai montré un
petit peu plus tôt les issus d'un petit
short de une sorte de vidéo très courte
qu'on peut désormais trouver sur la
plateforme Youtube vous voyez ici la
capture d'écran que j'en ai fait elle a
été vu un plus de 25 millions de fois
c'est normal c'est une vidéo très courte
par cet homme qui est un utilisateur
semble tout assez lambda et qui dit donc
c'est le bombardier B2 furtif arrive à
faire fort des Fairford il se trouve que
c'est une base de l'armée en britannique
ici donc se trouve au Royaume-Uni vous
avez donc aperçu une capture d'écran de
la vidéo j'ai fait moi-même une
recherche de géolocalisation avec
l'outil de Google Maps et on retrouve
donc les fameuses barrières vertes que
vous voyez c'est donc la confirmation
que cet avion qu'on voit sur la vidéo a
donc atterri ici cette base justement
elle est assez réputée pour héberger des
avions américains c'était notamment le
cas je vous le montre ici cette tactique
du gardien de 2003 c'était à l'époque de
la guerre en Irak et déjà à l'époque des
bombardiers américains c'est c'était
donc rendu sur cette base il faut dire
un mot également de cet appareil qu'on a
perçu le fameux B2 ce n'est pas
effectivement un appareil à nadant d'une
part parce qu'il est tout simplement
très rare l'armée américaine sur son
site un US Air Force donne ses
caractéristiques techniques que vous
apercevez ici et il y en a à peine 21 en
service coût unitaire 3 milliards pires
3 milliards de pièces une pas il me
direz-vous c'est un extrêmement
perfectionné et donc qui sert
effectivement à transporter des bombes
techniques des bombes nucléaires
notamment ici vous voyez c'est le
constructeur un hors-tropez woman
constructeur américain qui donne les
détails sur son site internet et un
petit article de la presse locale nous a
dit nous dit effectivement donc la
confirmation de ce que je vous disais
grâce à la géolocalisation et bien que
des bombardiers B2 sont bien atterris à
l'aéroport de Fairford de la Royal Air
Force le problème c'est que vous voyez
la date ici c'était le 13 mars 2020 rien
à voir donc avec la vidéo que je vous ai
montré au début de mon intervention
Raphaël en revanche Antoine d'autres
bombardiers sont bien arrivés en Pologne
absolument mais sauf qu'ils sont d'un
autre type ce sont des B52 et c'est le
ministre de la Défense polonais qui le
dit lui-même dans ce tweet que vous
voyez ici avec une photo du B52 vous le
voyez c'est un appareil qui n'a rien à
voir avec le précédent que je vous ai
montré là par exemple au niveau des
dates on retombe plus sur nos pas d'où
vous voyez on est au niveau du 2
septembre 2022 donc ça colle un peu plus
avec avec cet appareil cette actualité
effectivement des bombardiers qui
étaient qui sont donc venus en Pologne
pour la première fois c'était il y a
donc quelques semaines et qui est
également ont atterri effectivement
aussi sur la base de fer Ford la même
base que je vous ai montré un petit peu
plus tôt cette fois-ci dans le cadre de
la renforcement de la présence de l'OTAN
dans le cadre de la guerre en Ukraine
vous le voyez ici donc c'est plusieurs
bombardés cette fois un qui ont atterri
sur cette base britannique et à noter
également que ces mêmes B-52 avaient
fait une apparition dans à Stockholm
c'est nos confrères du fig qui nous le
relais c'est à l'occasion lorsque la
Suède avait voulu son adhésion à l'OTAN
c'est une certaine manière pour que
l'autre ans l'OTAN pardon monte ses
muscles à noter effectivement que ces
appareils de l'armée américaine ne sont
d'un tout autre type que celui que je
vous ai montré en début de mon
intervention 21 pour les B2 que vous
avez eu au début 744 exemplaires pour
cette B52 donc vous l'avez compris c'est
une vidéo sortie de son contexte avec
qui alimente plutôt une info que on peut
le dire cette fois-ci plutôt pro
ukrainienne il faut le dire Raphaël
merci Antoine fenaud c'était un faux
intox rester avec nous on se retrouve
dans 4 minutes pour un nouveau journal